hey
thanks oh that's loud hi um yes so i'm
julian chill
and um i quite like robots and
uh so we're just gonna have a little
play and see what kind of crazy things
we can do
with javascript and robotics so um
to do that uh we're just going to use
two two live
libraries one is cylon js and
uh the other one is johnny five which
has got such a cool
logo um so as everyone knows that
uh javascript is now taking over the
world and is going to be run on
absolutely everything
and so why not you know you have it on
servers you have it on phone so why not
have it on
bits of hardware so let's just have a
quick look see how easy
that is so um when you uh write your
first program you normally do
a hello world so in javascript you'd
sort of do uh console.log you know hello
world and and then you'd be like yeah
i'm a javascript developer and um so
with with um with with hardware the
equivalent of
of hello world is is the blink um
app so so this is uh cylon as you can
see it's only 17
uh lines of code and so we start off
creating an adapter to an arduino using
the femata protocol and fermata is a
really interesting protocol
it's based on midi which if any of you
were born in the 80s
you'll probably know what midi is and it
basically turns every pin
on the device into an api so you can
turn them on and off which is really
cool because then we can uh
script it with code so we create a
connection to an arduino we
set an led to be on pin 13 and then
every second we
toggle it on and off so if i just come
over here
plug this in
oh there's on the screen great so i just
oops don't add more code i'll just run
the code for this so what i'm doing
quickly
is just making sure it's all plugged in
it's plugged in somewhere but it's not
appearing on here no
okay let's just try it anyway uh node
no it's not connected demos died already
let's start that again
right so it's getting power what's going
on
let's follow the cables right let's just
move this
right um so that goes into
there which goes into
that one which goes hmm
you can't oh there we go it's come up
right so and i've just got a a
command line app that tells me the
device id
um because unfortunately when i'm using
the usb hub and changing between
demos it they keep changing id so i've
just set that there so if i
now run this code
yay that's now
blinking there we go yay hello world of
robots
wow that was complicated so you think
okay 17 lines of code i can turn an led
on what
use is that but you'll notice there's so
many like exit signs
and like old mobile phones used to have
a blinking light so we basically
can now write 90 of all hardware jobs
that you'll ever need so we can turn an
led off so yes
excellent right so let's quit that so
um some reason that the led stays turned
on afterwards so
um we can turn on one led and that's
really cool
um can we just um shift back to the code
oh that was quick right so now we can
turn on one led what happens if we turn
on
three leds so same code again we're
going to turn on a red pin a green pin
and a blue pin
or rgb so if i just
um connect up the ground
can we see that yay right so if i run
this code so it's exactly the same code
i just instead of one led
we're talking to three of them
yay we've got rgb values coming from an
led
so now we can color the world and make
it all beautiful
which is amazing let me just see your
microphone
so um we can turn on one led we can turn
on three leds and make color
a silly microphone right um can we go
back to the code
so that's cool so that was running on an
arduino and
if you wanted to run it oh hang on
it's gonna get complicated so if you
wanted to run it on
a beaglebone black um it's exactly the
same code
no just move down to there you just
change the adapter to beaglebone black
and if you wanted to run it on a spark
core
which i think they've just now renamed
themselves to photon or
electricity or something so all my
code's now wrong but
it's exactly the same code again you
just need to change the device driver
and could i have the camera
i don't know if you can see this so this
is a digispark
um tiny little usb kind of arduino
compatible thing
just with a little led on there and you
think why would i put an led on
something so small like this but imagine
if you just had this connected to your
computer
you could uh if you had a green led in
here as well you could toggle between
green and red depending on whether your
ci server
is working or broken which i think is
kind of cool and so
they're fun too right
so so we've turned on um let's do this
so we've turned on one led we turned on
multiple leds
but wouldn't it be cool if we could turn
on like loads of leds
so what you'd think wow that must be
really complicated
but it turns out all you need to know is
how to turn on one led and how to use an
array
and then bob's your uncle tada
rgb led strips
let's just leave that there simples how
pretty is that
let's have a look so leave that oh code
excellent right
so what have we done we've done
arduino's digisparks has ah
yes exciting right so um all those demos
were running for mata
on the devices and then i was
controlling them uh
from my machine but obviously when
you're going to deploy all of this in
the field you're not going to deploy a
macbook pro with an arduino
that would be really expensive actually
it's macbook air that'd be really
expensive
so that's why you
get something like this
can we sit which is a tesl
so i don't know how many of you have
ever seen a tesl it basically
uh runs uh javascript on the board
they say it run javascript on the board
actually converts it to lua but
effectively it runs javascript on the
board
so if i just plug this into my image
open i should do occasionally if i just
plug this in
can we just go to the screen quickly
so um all you need to do up there in my
terminal is just run the tesl library
and we're just going to run the basic
program blink
which should find the
tesla at the top connected to tesltm
it's let's just scroll up it's
converting our javascript to lua
and as you can see it says it's blinking
lots of times and if we move over here
to the camera
yay so that's actually running
javascript now
to blink these leds which if i was to
unplug this from my laptop and just plug
it into the main somewhere
i've now got an internet of things led
that i can deploy
all over the world which i think is
pretty cool
because it's all written in javascript
so that's great yay
cool um oh yeah
that was the thing so i haven't wired
this up but
so we've got rgb led strips we've got
single leds
uh wouldn't it be cool if you look like
a character from tron
so um this stuff is called el wire and
you basically put a voltage through it
and it lights up
so it's just connected to a battery pack
at the moment but imagine if you had it
connected
to a switch so it would pulse on and off
say
to some dubstep that would be pretty
cool and so
you and all your friends can now look
like tron let's just leave that there
that's
quite pretty and that's really really
simple
okay where are we going now ah yes
um so it's not just leds
you can do with this internet of of
things
you can also control real world devices
so there are so many cables
let's have a look
yes so um this here
is a um guitar effects pedal of mine
which i've soldered and wired into the
breadboard and connected it
to an arduino so that when um
i press the button it will play uh
party records on on spotify
unfortunately couldn't get the the wi-fi
working
but um so we we're not able to enjoy
party rockers but
the the idea is with that is you just
stamp on the pedal
and then music comes lights turn on
all controlled by javascript and as you
can see it's the same
kind of code we just um connected to an
arduino with
mata instead of the led driver we're
using the button
and um when the button's been released
or you can even do it when it's being
pressed so you can actually get two
commands
out of the button you can just do
different things
so i think that's that's kind of neat so
we can we can test the code to see
if that works
starting the connection so it should
hopefully if i press this
yay you can see so there's oh coming
back to the screen there's a bit of
noise
on the cable so it thinks it's been
pressed lots of times
and now it's gone and started up spotify
which is going to crash
oops but yes if if i had internet that
would we would have been party rocking
there so just imagine it in your minds
right so
um oh yeah so uh those are all
all really really fun things um
so uh has anyone seen
this it you may recognize it from a new
star wars film this is the older cousin
of the little robot that rolls around um
it's called a sphero so to use it you've
got to wake it up
by shaking it violently and
it should appear in my bluetooth along
with everybody else's phones
there it is so i just paired to this
while that's
pairing there's my library on the
on the mac it's really useless because
uh os 10 wants to manage bluetooth for
you but on linux you can automate
all of the bluetooth connections which
is really nice so that says it's
connected so if i run
my node app oh that's good
let's go to chrome so um basically the
the the sphero is has got motors so it
can roll around
uh on the floor and you know dogs and
cats love chasing it
uh and it's also got um leds in it as
you can see i quite like leds
so what i've done here i've taken a demo
from leah verou
where you can dynamically change the the
color on the screen
using all of the valid css colors and it
should change the color
of the sphero so if we change it from
this nice
pink to lime hopefully
the demo gods are with us no
why are you no change
oh well it should have changed color
oh well so you can imagine
that it's now red
oh well but the the the code for that is
is really nice and simple where's my
sphero gone
so all i did for that was um
require cylon again uh this time i'm
actually using
some web b framework so express and and
socket io
and then basically the web page sends
a integer via socket io and then the
cylon grabs that and then sets the color
sets the color of the zero to be to be
that color
which is uh kind of cool if it works so
i don't know why it didn't there we go
so that was that that was fun
right let's do some audio things now
that's that's always fun
so um let me just plug this in
has anyone ever played with or seen a
leap motion i don't know why it's
looking up there it's here
a leap motion it's basically an array of
um
sensors that is meant to add um
you know gesture control to your to your
computer so if we just run the
demo app here
is that going to load
huh
why is that not loading let's just
unplug that and try again
i wish you were all in the back room
with me earlier when all of this worked
perfectly
hmm okay the the sphero demo uh that's
so the leap motion demo
doesn't seem it's their app anyways
rubbish right
um but uh oh where's the codes gone
so i was thinking you know you can you
can use this you can swipe between web
pages
and you know do all that kind of thing i
thought that's not very exciting
wouldn't it be more exciting if you
could make karaoke
with a leap motion so if i
find the i think i can just run that
here so let's see
node harder
right so the idea of this is um
it starts harder faster stronger by daft
punk
and then
[Music]
using my amazing javascript skills i
basically loop this
array and on key tap i will play the
the audio tracks do the voiceover so
ready
[Music]
i mean it's not perfect
imagine having two of them that would be
really cool for those of you that are
shy
at karaoke after after a conference you
can just wave your hands about
that's kind of fun and the the code for
that is just yeah as you can see
same kind of thing create elite motion
device and connection
some nasty javascript and then on key
tap
run the the song the the keynote amongst
you will notice that i'm actually
uh forking af play so i've actually got
no way
of stopping the music on this demo
except for kill or af
play
but you know that it's not enterprise so
it's fine
okay right this is where it gets
exciting
ish if it all works okay um
so it's not just lights and leds
and whatnot that you can turn on
you can also use i should forget it's
over there
um uh playstation controllers and xbox
controllers
and for the four or four others in the
world of you that bought an uyer
uh you can use the ouya controller
so if i just um
pair this to the computer playstation
controller connected
excellent so then come over here
and so over here i have a parrot ar
drone i don't know if any of you have
ever
played with one or seen one before
it's basically a flight oh there it is
oh it's me
it's basically a flying death machine
so hopefully if this all works i should
be able to connect my wi-fi
to the drone so i've got two drones me
one slammer one is louise
i'm not sure which one this is
if there are any cliffs keep them away
there louise excellent
so i will connect to that
while i'm doing that i'll just show you
the code
so nice and simple you create a drone
create a controller for the the
playstation
and then on button controls do
different things so is that connected
yes so if i do node ps3
hopefully if i press start oh
it works so i should
theoretically be able to fly the drone
with a playstation controller and try
not to kill you
[Laughter]
sorry my bad
i can normally fly it longer than that
yes exactly you've got to pay for that
oh actually if if you wouldn't mind just
undoing the battery just in case
it spontaneously decides to fly oh no
actually i do
i need it back don't i i remember
that's right i'll do it great
so um if if you thought that wasn't
dangerous
enough you know you think
okay i've got a
where's the
let's close that you think if that's not
dangerous enough
uh you know you control it with a
playstation controller which is really
fun
and it's really intuitive you know being
of the xbox generation we're great with
that sort of thing
i thought wouldn't it be cool to use a
playstation 2 dance mat
so if i follow the cables
and plug this in
and then run the code
and we're still connected to the drone
is the code gonna run
i don't know so hopefully if i press
start
magic should happen
oh can we go to the screen and have some
audio
because not that
because drones like dancing can we have
the screen
with my laptop drone's like dancing to
gangnam style
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so that was fun
don't look at the screen you're not
meant to see that yet
oh i need some water that was really hot
um yeah so drones really like dubstep as
well
uh as well as um korean dance music
they're not very much of a fan of
country and western you think they would
be you know with all the different
maneuvers but
turns out they don't like it
okay by the way i'm available for kids
parties
and whatnot just i might decapitate them
with a drone
okay so i've been playing with drones
and let me just unplug it because i
really don't trust the random
wi-fi signals that could randomly
control it
i don't trust any of you either um
so i've been playing with drones for a
little bit and i thought that's
fun but what else could we do
and so what i did to the other drone
just look at the camera
so friends of mine
um built this little grabber so you know
everyone's
amazon and everybody else is talking
about delivery drones
well uh we built one and so just a
little rubber
you know pencil rub at the end on a
servo and it will open
and it will close and um on the
drone itself is a little gobot program
connected to a
connected to a digispark that open and
closes the servo so you can fly the
drone around
and drop payload which is a great idea
until you realize the drone can't take
much weight
so you have to use your imagination for
this so if you
think now drones delivering things
what could that do what kind of magic
could you build
and i got started to thinking about
angry birds
i was like that's kind of cool i wonder
if our newfound drone
with its uh dropper capabilities
and angry birds could you know be
combined into something like
angry drones
so for this you have to imagine that
we're using this drone but unfortunately
it just
can't do uh deal with the weight so
with all of that you can see
can you see my little piggy yes let's
connect this
up
right
so um let's load the code
let me just check that we've got usb
yes let's go to the code what do i call
it
not that one i name all my files
so i can remember them and then i
completely forget what i call them
it's in here somewhere
it will tell me
it was just proximity
oh it's because i commented at the code
earlier that would be why
quick hacking
again um the idea was that it was going
to place a spotify track of angry beds
while we did this but uh the internet's
not so much working so
um the idea is with this um the the the
the pigs thought it was a
unnecessary advantage of the birds you
know being dropped by drones
so they too uh have some cunning plans
if we could just look at the camera you
might be able to see there's a little
ir sensor oh sorry a sonar sensor
attached to our smart pig so
if we run this code
if we could just quickly look so this is
using uh johnny five
and hopefully
if it's all wired up correctly it should
crash
no
hmm
[Music]
oh it's not working oh basically
um the idea is the the as the as the
bird flies
closer um when it when it gets
uh within less than 10 centimeters
the pig will shout out if we can have
some volume
oh my god did that work
oh my god you heard me
so that's what it should have done but
there we go
so amazon eat your heart out i've
painted it painted all this stuff
angry drones it's a thing
crazy crazy ah yes right
so this is all really really thirsty
work all of this
conference talking and plugging and
plugging drones and
whatnot
and i thought wouldn't it be cool
if i could have some kind of uh drink
while i'm on stage
but you know drinking on stage is quite
dangerous because there's definitely a
fine line between drinking a little
and drinking a lot so
with that in mind i've built this
we can see that there so just while you
look at that i will
find the correct codes to run
is that it yes all right let's just make
sure we got the right port
so what we have on the on the not on the
screen on over on the table
is a breathalyzer
um as you do sorry let me just remove
all of that
make sure we cut the right port
copy and paste that in there excellent
right
um so if i just run this code
excellent so a breath this is just a
standard breathalyzer that your average
police person will have when you've had
too many to drink and you're driving
which you should not do
so that isn't a thing oh that's that one
um and what it is it's connected
uh via uh using server sent events
to this um web page with this um
hopefully this little
bar and i haven't been drinking much
today as you can
tell can we go back to the screen so if
i breathe in this
it shouldn't change if we're actually
getting so
look at the console are we getting
resending events should be
um seriously i haven't been drinking if
this is working if i open up this bottle
of
random uh hungarian alcohol if this is
working
which it doesn't can we go look at my
screen
no that should be going up because this
is alcoholic
ah i don't know but um it's cool
and i thought that what you could kind
of do with this is you could like gamify
drinking so you could have a competition
with your friends so like to make sure
who drinks the least
you know be sensible about it so it's
kind of like fitbit
but for our whole
so that's cool but obviously i haven't
got a drink at the moment so
it would be cool to have a drink on this
stage
and it's it's quite lucky that i
actually have
a machine for that so move my hair right
this is fiddly let's work out what we
need to plug in
okay so you probably can't quite see
over here
i have a um
arduino with a set of relays that's
connected to a set of pumps
that if i find the cable
let's just plug this so i have to do all
this in order so if i plug that in
fingers crossed that will switch on yes
okay now
i plug in the pumps with my american
eu to british safety plug system
oh they started already that's not right
because i haven't started the code
that's why
probably had to do it in order right
let's quickly look at the code
where are we drinkybot yes
let me find that that's up here let's
run that
so the way drinkybot works is um
it's currently running on an arduino but
it could also be running on
a raspberry pi or a beaglebone or a
tesla or all the other things we've seen
and it listens to mqtt messages
and for those who don't know mqtt is a
great kind of publish and subscribe
protocol that all the internet of stuff
and things uses
and so what we do now i can plug this
back in is we can send it
a message to say make us a drink
and if i put the helpfully labeled red
wires
there should be another one somewhere ah
so in the drink
if i could have if there are any
volunteers that would like to try
um robotic shots
got three glasses
three things i don't know how well you
can see that on the screen
over there and so if we then go
over to my screen
uh connect to the message broker
so hopefully if i publish a message yay
i don't know if you can hear that if we
can look over over here
it should start pumping alcohols
yay i don't know how well you can see
this
so the pumps i'm using here are called
peristaltic pumps you use them in things
like dishwashers
in blood transfusion machines
and so you can actually send an exact
amount of alcohol
and this is all internet connected
and it's obviously just higgledy piggly
on the table but you could imagine you
could 3d print this
and and have it all nicely with some
leds and you might think whoa you crazy
person you know doing it why would you
do this
turns out people have and they're
selling them for thousands of pounds on
kickstarter
this could be yours for a mere 30 pounds
so um if i could if we wait for that to
finish
thank you so it hasn't done much because
it runs quite slow but
if i could have a volunteer from the
audience ah film
would you like to try
[Applause]
yay so um that's basically all my demos
i've just got a couple of other bits of
pieces that i haven't shown you um so
i bought this expensive cable which is a
dmx cable
which is meant to control these
disco lights but unfortunately i don't
know whether it was my cable or node
dmx itself it doesn't work
but we can still just turn them on so
the idea would be
that you'd be able to control um disco
lights and smoke machines
and all those other fun things all via
node.js
which is obviously super fun times and
um you might also be thinking what other
kind of
fun bits of hardware
is a thing missing um could i build
and somewhere on this table is a
temperature and humidity sensor
and there's this which is a moisture
sensor
so as we've seen we can control water
we can now measure temperature and
humidity we can also measure
uh whether your soil's damp or not and
you could build an automated plant
growing system
for your for your home you know to grow
those legal tomatoes that all of your
friends
like to have all all through the
internet of stuff
so on that slightly dubious note i guess
that's me so thank you very much
you